this week we've got iPhone fix
artificial moon and generous youtuber
that's like a boater growing [ __ ] that
generous youtuber why what does that
even mean
I just feel like it's [ __ ] I mean
won't guess I saw it in the last story
but for the first story have you guys
heard of Beauty gates with the iPhone no
do I need it what is it you don't need
anything
it puts makeup on you you try to have a
good day there's a beauty gates
controversy that so they're pretty much
saying that the new cameras on the new
iPhones yeah they're dumb as they're so
good so you like it a lot of people hate
it
Wow dang it's like way too artificial
looks like you're already wearing a [ __ ]
ton of filters when it's done the camera
but maybe you mean iPhone X no XS this
one's the iPhone X this is the XS really
the one that they have fine doesn't take
pictures like this mine that's what you
compare it to the 10 like if we both
take our phones you know we take a photo
it's gonna be that just looks like
there's more lightly like it's taking it
more light yeah so this one it's also
airbrushed looking it's super it's
literally the same picture telling she
took two selfies you know I mean like
how can you even know yeah she did it
she took jewels like this yeah she's
looking at both like it looks like one
one just looks like it was adjusted more
for life I mean it looks like it erased
the shadows it did oh look no her hair
is different look at the bottom of her
hair we're on the right side that yeah
that strand of hair is different on the
other it's like what's because I feel
you it doesn't think like the exact I
could say the same picture twice try it
like this
yeah I've done it goodbye accident put
like oh I mean like it took like
multiple pictures oh I gotta pay more
attention cuz I took like some nature
shots and I don't think that the
mountains look airbrushed
filters recognize skin colors our people
like the Oh like [ __ ] I should get the
new iPhone yeah like it like it just
made it edit it for you already in rooms
that you want the edited I wanted to
remove my pimples if you like some
people are very proud of their like
freckles or whatever it is yeah and it's
just too much is that a lot of people
cuz I would agree more if like you made
your eyes bigger and it's in that like I
like the snapchat filters yeah but then
cuz then it doesn't look like you
anymore
my mom's boned it has been doing that
for years it's an LG a lot of the LG
phones do that do was they tried some
yeah they have like automatic filters
like all my aunts and my mom they take
pictures and like air brushes all the
wrinkles out it's a cable this automatic
here's another example
LG's making a k-pop face oh that's
iJustine yeah I just so this is with the
10 i like the note 1s and then the note
I know this is no it looks way better
the nose you know cuz no it is not
iPhone so what brand dealership
promoting included in the article yeah I
think the difference is this just takes
in more light the note looks hella good
but what they don't show you is once you
Instagram no one it's all pixelated and
[ __ ] what about the pixel I wanted to
get the pixel because it's all the same
things for Android but like how does
Instagram know like oh no this is
Android I'm gonna [ __ ] it up that's the
way they like buy an Apple but if you'd
notice though I always have to sharpen
all my photos and I have an iPhone but
as soon as it goes on Instagram it
automatically blur is it really well it
compresses it no matter what
cuz you're sending your picture
somewhere else but Android ones I don't
know why they're super [ __ ] up what if
you take a picture like what the camera
camera and then you get it onto your
phone that's like a note or whatever and
then you upload it is it still shitty
well that's a good question I don't know
no there is it's fine it's good because
that's all our barbel photos they are on
a regular yeah but they put it on an
iPhone
they don't take a DSLR and then put it
on a note that's business so yeah so now
Apple says that in the upcoming update
the iOS update that they're gonna see if
they can somehow fix that so what's
happening and just give an option
they're gonna put the ugly my phone like
this yeah yeah so what they're saying is
that it's the result of aggressive noise
reduction and so it's also all the smart
HDR chooses to merge the exposures and
that's what's happening to your guys
dawn that's not so the AI inside of the
phone is like I don't like your wrinkles
no it's just the the noise reduction and
like there's more detail and the
highlights and the shadows honestly I
have the 10 and I [ __ ] hate the
camera like every time I take a photo it
looks really blurry I'm like what is
wrong with this phone it's list of the
front-facing or the boat do you wipe the
grease off the lens first that's such a
basic question a lot of people saw this
is tip have you seen her house before I
take any picture you always wipe every
so if you're gonna make me take five
pictures of you I'll go like this take a
picture probably doing it in between
each time it's so frustrating a
professional has the eight and his phone
I in my opinion takes better if yeah I
have the eight phone
he took it with both cameras and the
eights better yeah I'll take a photo and
I'll be like in the best lighting like
it still looked like blurry around the
edges and I'll take it with his and it
looks crisp like what the [ __ ] 10 it
doesn't work I don't know I don't like
it but yeah they're gonna say that
they're gonna fix this in for the excess
I love updater for my fault I love them
too you know your said the 10 turn XS
max jeez
okay it's like the 10 took a bunch of
drugs like
nuts but the pictures are good I don't
even use my camera anymore this is my
phone that's what I'm like taking
selfies or anything every time I take it
oh my god I don't know with their clunky
beautiful face shut up thank you but I
don't there's always gonna be something
wrong with your picture to your horse
yeah for sure if it's not like the
details in my skin it's like my head's
too small for my shoulder is some bull
something that you can't even figure
it's much it hurts yeah I always have a
problem with my you should have to watch
those videos it's like this is how you
could make yourself look better in
pictures and you could like contort your
body to look all like supermodel I'm
like does it say Oh watching those
videos that I'm like damn that girl does
not look like that how does she do that
those models what did they do look like
this right yes the angle the name is
homie
oh is that Amanda yeah yeah no one does
that oh no it's the [ __ ] oh yeah on
the seat great not work so and also like
this hey squat down what like that it's
the realest squat down where you at
like this do you does it in her picture
yeah I'm like I've done that at least
three times I've never done that cuz
like I can't do it right totally
Instagram status yeah alright next story
so have you guys heard that China is
planning on launching artificial moons
yes they're launching them talking about
drugs well when we first look for it
what does that mean how you gonna launch
a moon wait why do they want to moon
again to have more moon cake season it's
not what a satellite is a fake moon yes
well yeah it's like an orbiting around
so to the addition of a mower that's um
hi [ __ ] question the definition of
the moon
no what is it oh it says it's a natural
satellite satellite go [ __ ] so we've
been throwing us out there yeah yeah so
it's saying that if the moon is a
natural satellite of the earth visible
by reflected light from the Sun
so China is saying that by 2020 they
want to launch an artificial moon to
light up the night sky and like a
certain part of China that's not which
would be a satellite that reflects the
Sun but it only shows in China because
the earth you know rotate for a moon to
cosmetic resistant rotates with the
earth so they're saying that oh it's a
good tracking like a GoPro tracker like
like that drones oh yeah magnetic but
what's the point it's just to look
pretty so it's that's panic it's not oh
that's wondering well I was trying to
tell you but okay so what's the point -
so the point is that they want to
reflect light so it will be eight times
brighter than the moon and they want to
reflect light on these urban areas which
will then save a lot of money because
then you won't need street lights
because it has sex you can't turn it off
so it's controlled by men and so they
come they could turn it off they can dim
it they can do all this got a dimmer
switch that's imagine it's like a clap
on clap like nah dude it has to come
together to grab it this would be in
China though that's genius we hardly
gonna put it in there like it just gonna
rock in a giant over what are they gonna
do just [ __ ] throw it up you can't
make these jokes when you're smart I'm
not that smart
they're calling it in to illumination
satellites and it will orbit above the
tiny city of Chengdu Chengdu Chengdu so
from what I heard that's the Silicon
Valley how are they gonna get to Silicon
Valley of China no he knows what I'm
doing
oh that's like a new pop and pop that's
what I can just has two studios okay oh
where is it I don't know
China finally did an eco-friendly thing
that's one thing right so they're
planning to launch this first satellite
in the end they want to have three
satellites right yeah cuz then they
don't have to spend like electricity and
all
what if they have their bootleg version
of Elon Musk along mal [ __ ] [ __ ] up so
so like for example in the forest right
you got like nocturnal creatures now you
have a leopard that's the waiting part
to deal yeah this what comes out he's
like oh hell no so they thought of that
already
oh really oh alright so they're saying
that they will save that the city will
save an estimated 1.2 billion the one or
about a hundred and seventy four million
dollars every year the animals I'm
telling you that they solve that okay
I'm not gonna get it but they don't say
how they're gonna feed every year but
about um okay so the moon like affects
the tides and the in the ocean like what
if all our Moon's affect our oh there's
no surfers in China it's only gonna be
China it blocks our moves a title
interference so initially they're gonna
be testing this moon over a deserted
area like an uninhabited desert so they
can test out the desert as animals the
scorpions are not gonna come out at
night anymore what are they gonna look
like cuz they won't be eight times
brighter than the moon
eight times brighter is it like an
iPhone like to put the stuff up and down
I know I feel bad for those people that
can't sleep when unless it's pitch black
to me as [ __ ] I feel bad for all the
rapists - I used to count on it being
dark and now it is all bright I can't do
my job just leave him here
see they don't consider everybody else
we get it
Bart in your name's Bart it's not
Bartholomew I thought it was breath
Allah no it's Barton what Martin do your
mother stop that bar just kept messy
that's how you needed bar don bartolo mo
all right so for our last story this
youtuber decided to leave a ten thousand
dollar tip for this waitress after just
like after she'd just served them
watched her while they were blogging
while they were well see the thing is
that's not saying this was [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] his mother [ __ ] okay so
this dude his name is mr. beast and he's
known for doing like the most randomest
types of videos like this one video he
did was like to see how many toys cards
could pull an actual card I was tight
and then this other one is like he spent
oh I've seen this stuff before he spent
$30,000 on scratch off tickets just to
see what he won like things like that
like random YouTube I mean a point nine
million y'all sound like viral ideas
don't start off doing I'm a nun [ __ ]
this guy and maybe he's poor no but the
story is about the waitress unfuck you
okay okay I get it he just has money to
like just [ __ ] around but he also does
like generous things like this or he
will just leave a fat tip and but is he
vlog it can he claim it for sure because
she said that she so the waitress said
that she noticed that there were people
filming and so she asked like wait what
the hell is this cuz she thought it was
a joke when she saw like the huge stack
of cash and then the people were just
like oh make sure to oh he tipped in
cash yeah that's tight it's one of those
ones that's ten grand right there that
watereth and they take me for me oh my
god that's amazing that's that's 10k
yeah imagine you just show up to work oh
he doesn't look like hi oh wow
they're buddies oh damn that's crazy
yeah so the waitress said that she felt
weird like keeping it all cuz she didn't
do anything she's like this could have
been anyone else on my shift
true feels weird keeping all this money
you should never feel weird right keep
the money girl
because it's like winning the lotto yeah
I feel weird
no no so let me explain what she did
so what she ended up doing is giving
$200 to each person working during her
shift the title should be generous
waitress and then $100 to the rest of
the servers and then she kept the
remaining $800 for herself how many
people are working 3 well she'll be
casually Joanie had 300 left do the math
she only at 800 left oh she did there's
only an 800 left so nine thousand no
money $200 went to people there's a big
kitchen staff 92 people working there
might be a giant cake karma she's gonna
get it back in yeah I mean know that I
mean there could be like a 50 person
staff
depends on how big the restaurant is
crazy is this guy just he did this just
for like a social experiment maybe just
to see what would happen I think that
for you - well that's what he does
yeah he does random things like that's
real did you record her doing giving it
away I don't know that's so cool of the
waitress I know all right those in North
Carolina say I would [ __ ] I didn't want
to be like the mean one I mean I would
be like okay here's 5k for everybody
okay though yeah she could have given
two K right she could have give it an
okay exactly I mean you still want to
give some but like give me 9,000 or just
quit I [ __ ] quit I'm rich it's only
10k though well you could have like a
two-month vacation even people that she
didn't even like at work you know
imagine there's one [ __ ] that she's
like not you Beijing I would have done
that
she's like I'm keeping a thousand nice
maybe like I like you I like you whew oh
you're my two these chairs are giving
down on her I would always say [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you mr. Beach mr. Beach mr. beep
Channel and he did upload the video I
haven't seen it yet but it has 3.7
million views
and fallen do you think you might have
the money from that more than 10k how
many ads he put in that video at all
it's a 12 minute video so at least two
at least
damn that's yeah he is making a lot
though oh yeah that's a pretty smart
there's a lot of his videos get millions
in minute I'm gonna be even considering
brand deals or merge our IG brand deals
this is just like work money for him
yeah he's like I got to go to work tan
my tip or $10,000 just for water too
though you got to remember like she
didn't even serve on food or anything
it was just only water that's part of
his whole plan dude if I had a co-worker
that they didn't like plus my table or
whatever I'll be like so bitter like
you're not getting [ __ ] cuz you didn't
[ __ ] refill my [ __ ]
customers water so you become king with
the 10000 oh oh yeah I abuse my power
like crazy if I because it's like if
you're on the same lower level as
everybody else and then all of a sudden
you could be on top
[ __ ] that I'm not gonna be humble about
it [ __ ] you I see the manager going like
oh ya know you were mean to me [ __ ] you
I love Jamal you never get on Joe's bad
leg never because I am very nice when
they're all my goods yeah I'll be like
oh you help me out here is $5,000 we're
going half half mm-hmm a cup of water
here you go
[Music]